fraude corruption abus de confiance
benyamin nétanyahou est visée par une
triple procédure d'inculpation dans la
sphère appelé 4000 le premier ministre
israélien est soupçonné d'avoir modifié
et des lois et réglementations en
vigueur en faveur d'un grand groupe de
communication et cela en échange d'une
couverture médiatique favorable
la seconde la ferme il concerne la
remise de cadeaux par de richissimes
personnalités en contrepartie d'appui
financier ou de services personnels et
benyamin netanyahou fait ainsi suspecté
d'avoir reçu pour 235 mille euros de
cigares de luxe bouteille de champagne
bijoux et voyages à l'étranger
la troisième la sphère 2000 tourne elle
aussi au tour des médias
elle concerne un accord que netanyahou
aurait tenté de passer avec le
propriétaire du yedioth ahronoth le plus
grand quotidien payant israélien là
encore on reproche au chef du
gouvernement israélien de s'être assuré
une couverture médiatique favorable à
des accusations niées en bloc par
benyamin nétanyahou qui dénonce une
chasse aux sorcières
la gauche est parfaitement qu'elle ne
peut pas nos battre dans les urnes
alors depuis trois ans elle mène une
chasse aux sorcières sans précédent pour
renverser le gouvernement de droite que
je dirige est installé à sa place le
gouvernement gauchistes de lapider ganz
ce château de cartes s'écroulera
totalement après les élections j'ai
l'intention de continuer à vous servir
en tant que premier ministre pendant
encore de nombreuses années pour tenter
d'échapper à la justice tous les moyens
sont bons pour benyamin nétanyahou son
parti le likoud a d'abord proposé un
projet de loi destiné à protéger le
premier ministre contre des poursuites
judiciaires et à limiter le pouvoir de
la cour suprême
un texte qui a provoqué la colère des
israéliens qui sont descendus en masse
dans les rues
autre tentative une demande d'immunité
parlementaire envisagé en début d'année
par le chef du gouvernement israélien
j'ai l'intention de me présenter au
tribunal pour rejeter en bloc toutes les
accusations portées contre moi pour
pouvoir continuer à mener israël vers
tous ses succès remarquables
j'ai l'intention de demander l'immunité
au président de la knesset pour être
dans mon droit pour assurer mon devoir
est ma mission continue à vous servir
pour l'avenir d'israël
ses opposants n'ont pas tardé à réagir
avigdor lieberman et benny gantz ont
rapidement fait savoir qu'il rejetterait
sa demande
la seule chose qui intéressait qui
intéresse benyamin nétanyahou et
l'immunité en premier ministre n'est pas
au dessus des lois et du système
judiciaire
sans le soutien de ces deux formations
impossible pour benyamin nétanyahou de
bénéficier de la majorité nécessaire
pour l'adoption de sa demande d'immunité
il fait donc marche arrière et dénonce
je cite un cirque de l'immunité
j'ai informé le président du parlement
que je retirais ma demande d'immunité
plus tard j'allais en tirer les
allégations ridicules formulées contre
moi mais pour l'instant je ne laisserai
pas mes adversaires politiques utiliser
ceci pour troubler la démarche
historique que je mène malgré ses ennuis
judiciaires benyamin nétanyahou
s'accroche à la tête du pays sans
interruption depuis onze ans après 500
jours de crise et 3 élections
législatives benny gantz et benyamin
nétanyahou font finalement réussi à
former un gouvernement d'union nationale
elle les deux hommes seront donc tour à
tour chef du gouvernement chacun pendant
18 mois
mais si l'impasse politique à trouver
une issue est les menaces judiciaires
elle plane toujours au dessus de
benyamin nétanyahou qui encourt jusqu'à
dix ans de prison pour corruption et 3
pour fraude et abus de confiance
[Musique]